this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
well good afternoon everybody and
welcome to
Thursday November the 1st 2012 session
in our series on green technologies and
transportation thanks very much for
putting up with my skype intro last week
from Sapporo Japan and I'm glad to be
back with you in person cause we can
talk after it and drink coffee and so
forth at the beginning I do want to say
a special word of thanks to Alan miner
who has the Alan miner Foundation which
has given us some additional financial
support for this series and the venture
capital firm that he runs here in the
valley is called Sun bridge partners so
you may see that on some of our
information related to the series today
we are taking the other end of the
spectrum from last week but last week we
were talking about a crowd-sourced
sensor network that was giving
information about environmental factors
and traffic patterns in Beijing this
week we're going to talk about materials
and a major development that's happened
in the material world and transportation
if you go on United Airlines somewhere
for your Thanksgiving or Christmas
vacations the president comes on at the
beginning of the you know the the safety
pitch talking about the new Boeing 787
that United as ball and the 787 is an
incredibly efficient vehicle and one of
the major reasons behind this is the
extensive use of carbon fiber composite
materials and these are developed and
also commercialized by Touareg which has
the world's poor a industries which has
the world's leading market share for
this kind of material and we're very
fortunate to have one of the key people
who is involved in the development of
these materials since the mid 1980s to
come with us to come from Seattle to
give a presentation in our series just
for today
he arrived this morning and has to go
back on a 7:00 a.m. flight tomorrow
and so mr. Toshi Yuki Kondo is the
president and CEO of touré composites
America which is located kind of right
across the street from Boeing and he
joined Toure in 1985 right after
finishing his master's in synthetic
chemistry at the University of Kyoto and
at first he was doing technical R&D work
on large-scale structure development and
from there he became the general manager
in charge of toriko which is the brand
name for Toure carbon fiber materials
and was with the advanced composites
planning and administration department
in Toure and Japan then he became
general manager of the production
department for tarika and since 2009
he's been in his current position with
Toure composites America so let me turn
over the microphone to mr. Kondo thanks
so much for coming down and give this
talk today
good afternoon everyone I'm Tasha condo
and thank you for the very kind
introduction and I really thank you very
much for the giving us giving me the
opportunity to introduce how a cup of
hypothesis today okay so first let me
let me introduce our torah group and our
carbon fiber business and how contribute
the carbon fiber to the environment our
transportation trans efficient
transportation and Boeing 787 as you
know dr. Dacia said that Boeing seven
stable expensively using our carbon
fiber material almost 50 percent doable
structural weight is composed
of carbon fiber so I'm I will touch
about the how we can achieve the very
right to weight efficient airplane with
Boeing and then conclusion okay
this is a outline of Torah group tour a
established 1926 they are almost 85
years ago as a radium manufacturer Tory
it's that name is abbreviation of toil
rayon Toyo means oriental and the Ray
Liam means rayon visit chemical fiber so
we Tory was established as a rayon much
luxury in 99 1926 and then we expand our
business with fibers and textiles
plastics and chemicals those are kind of
our foundation business however as you
can imagine fibers closing textiles or
plastics that those business are kind of
mature business so we need to we need to
expand the in in the different field
like I curated products or carbon fiber
and composite materials together with
you know life science or something like
that our sales consolidated sales is
almost see one thousand five hundred
billion dollar a billion yen this is 15
almost 16 fifteen billion dollars modern
model 15 billion dollars maybe 2020 yeah
18 billion dollars
and this is the segment series by
segment hi buzz and textiles and
prosecution and and chemicals as we
those are still our main business
however we put lots of resources to to
expand those you know new business this
is our major product I'm not sure you
are familiar with unique row
unique row is a kind of a parallel
parallel declara of the United States
and in Japan and we extensively you know
supplying the this heat tech material
which has a function have if you know
this underwear absorb the water it some
generate the can heat so very warm even
in the winter we can this underwear can
keep the earth temperature body
temperature that those kind of function
allows us to you know to go into the
Uniqlo business our business with
Unicron
so this vinca heat take underwear whoa
Unicron war sell almost 100 million
underwears in a year and then other
products this is I think yeah you are
familiar with SunChips the compostable
or biodegradable they were edible but
back we tore a to actually totally
pressed America located in Rhode Island
they
reducing this back biodegradable back we
have interferon medical products we are
we are producing and then our carbon
fiber materials the extensively as I
said Boeing 707 using our carbon fiber
production today is a material company
so our core technology or our base
technology is based technologies are
polymer chemistry organic sensitive
organic synthetic chemistry or
biotechnology we combine those top
technologies then put our nanotechnology
with the nanotech growth technology we
have lots of you know materials for the
for the various product this is also a
kind of you know our business the change
of our business fields you know this is
a rail we stopped the play on business
in 1960s and fibers and textiles resin
and films and new product like carbon
fiber materials okay let's change the
topics to Cobo fiber itself carbon fiber
is carbon the fiber fiber you know we
this fiber that means you know very sink
wrong materials so if we see
if we go to the you know I don't know
the yakitori restaurant or Japanese
restaurant you you you have usually a
check you can see a charcoal charcoal is
the kind of wow you know Kabul
however taco reason this type of you
know shape however carbon fiber we call
choco taco but five fibrous shape so
first we make a krill nitrile acrylic
fiber acrylic fiber is used for blanket
was later artificial sweater or
something do those same fiber and then
we burn or break room the acrylic fiber
to make carbon fiber but carbon fiber
shows very superior performance if we
compare with steel specific gravity one
for so still very light lightweight and
high strength specific tensile strength
ten times of still ten times stronger
than steel and modulus you know the how
been how durable for bending seven times
of steel and rust-free those you know
very good performance makes carbon fiber
to you know you can use a lot of
application in in 1971 today
commercialized their carbon fiber as
our first producer and Cabo Wabo a pride
golf shaft too upright to golf shaft in
1973 then but we need lots of time to
expand our business 2010 almost 40,000
tongue hot dog carbon fiber it's used in
in the world these are the application
of carbon fiber as I said that those are
the with those advantages carbon fiber
can be used or airplane automobile sit
both the bicycle uranium enrichment
centre fuel huge oil cell window braid
what note P she was she energy tank or
something that those lots of application
is the acabo fiber has been applied in
various application so carbon fiber
since this is carbon fiber it with its
right weight reduction of carbon fiber
carbon dioxide emission contribute a
carbon fiber can contribute there to
deduce of carbon dioxide emission all
generation of green energy were
alternative ul waters especially
carbon dioxide emission the reduction of
carbon dioxide emission this is a very
you know carbon fiber contributes a lot
of carbon dioxide emission reduction of
a fish emission emission reduction so I
with with several sides I can explain
the how carbon fiber contribute to
reduce the carbon dioxide emission we
JCM a means Japan carbon fiber
manufacturing Association we today is a
one of the member of GMA and automobile
we choose model for example automobile
those you know the specification of the
old model of automobile and this is a
specification of model airplane material
Association of Manufacturers Association
and if we choose this mode model
automobile you know mileage is 9.8
kilometre per litre that means C 3 2020
yeah 25 mile per gallon or something
lifetime 10 years automobile rest time
is 10 years so and almost to ten
thousand kilometer per year
so in the lifetime carbon dioxide is
emitted during drives oh right
not the material production or assembly
those are main portion of carbon dioxide
emission since carbon fiber on the scene
as I said that we burn what we grew the
fiber two carbon acrylic fiber two
carbon fiber so during producing carbon
fiber we use lots of energy
however material production the carbon
dioxide emission in material production
is only 12% you know drive right is a
major portion to emit the carbon dioxide
and if we use the carbon fiber to the
automobile we can reduce the body body
weight from 1,400 children to of less
than 1,000 children 30% reduction can be
achieved by using carbon fiber
reinforced plastics an acronym that
you'll hear more about in the future
cfrp that is carbon fiber reinforced
plastic yes and if the airplane use the
carbon fiber reinforced plastics 20%
weight
can be achieved actually seven and seven
this is a Boeing 707 the blue part blue
portion is carbon fiber so main wing
were huge or in panache or in a bottle
thing those part is made of carbon fiber
reinforced plastics so 20% weight
reduction can be achieved so it
automobile you know thirty percent
weight reduction means 0.5 tone carbon
dioxide reduction per cow per year so
recei and also airplane twenty percent
weight reduction means 2075 a 700 ton
carbon dioxide emission can be reduced
see so this is a Racine so come
automobile carbon fiber one tonne of
carbon fiber if we may produce one ton
of carbon fiber 20 tonne of carbon
dioxide was emitted however if
automobile use one tonne of carbon fiber
15 tonne 50 tonne of carbon dioxide
emission both reduced is reduced means
satatam
of carbon dioxide can be produced during
the lifetime of automobile
so that means 19 million tonne of carbon
dioxide in 37 million of the mobile in
the world how about the airplane cabo
501 20 tonne carbon dioxide emission
that is same
however if airplane use 1 tonne of
carbon fiber protein hundred ton of
carbon dioxide can be reduced the huge
so that means from the viewpoint of LCA
life cycle assessment of those in
automobile or airplane carbon fiber was
considered as an environmental friendly
material even though the production of
carbon fiber in the production of carbon
fiber they you know emit the carbon
dioxide however if we can consider the
from the viewpoint of LCA life cycle
assessment kabaah fiber is very you know
environmental friendly material ok we
will change the topics and I think you
can understand the a carbon fiber is a
very you know mechanically the very
superior material than still and also
economical friendly all environmental
friendly material however its take it
took long time to
get this point seven seven we need lots
of you know walk two together with you
know airplane manufacturer Boeing first
we commercialized the carbon fiber and
Boeing use our carbon fiber as a
secondary structure has no kind of test
you know secondary structure means if
this structure broke airplane can't fry
even though this you know pot broke
warfare airplane can fly that is
secondary structure like you know this
is spoiler or trap or something like
that those are not essential material
essential parts of the airplane so going
first upright carbon fiber to the
secondary structure for seven five seven
four seven six seven those are 1980s and
then Boeing first applied our carbon
fiber to a primary structure of 77227
empennage or those bath to support the
huge those are primary structure and to
in order to achieve the primary
structure carbon fiber we have very big
you know breaks
in technology as you can see this is a
impact resistance and this is the impact
energy but column accesses impact energy
so conventional carbon composite our
CFRB if peak impact energy applied
impact resistance deteriorate
deteriorate very much
for example maybe this is a carbon
composite if impact energy applied this
material easily break that is that was a
conventional carbon composite so we can
we can't use this kind of carbon
composite like you know primary
structure because if you know something
poor fell in on the amp energy the
emperor's history broke it's not a raw
material so we applied the energy
absorbing material in the carbon fiber
composite then we solved this issues and
then going up right our carbon fiber to
the triple seven primary structure
after that you know we put a plant in in
the United States this is a carbon fiber
brand and we Tory compost America this
is a pre pre impregnated resin
impregnated seed product sobriety Boeing
and Boeing decided to you know use the
our Taurus carbon fiber to 7/7 old
primary for the old primary structural
voice MSM then we also working together
with next generation aircraft with
Boeing so not only the good performance
of material or you know not all and also
we shoved Boeing the common fiber is
environmental friendly material however
it takes twenty was thirty years to
achieve Boeing's decision to use carbon
fiber extensively the primary structure
so let me summarize of the carbon fiber
application for airplane so eighty a
1982 767 boeing apprise him is six seven
carbon fiber carbon fiber is a pride to
Boeing 767 second district as a
secondary structure just three percent
of aircraft
and 1995 boy decided to use carbon fiber
as a primary structure for 3 / 7 10
tones almost 10 turns off come on
ow tenten's and 3 percent of structure
then 7 7 2010 primary structure
approximately 35 tones homes 50% of
structure weight was made by composite
20% reduction so in 30 40 years in 40
years after we commercialize the acabo
fiber we developed or we have been they
will have been studying to make stronger
carbon fiber you know in 1970 if we
compared this almost 5 times stronger
than first commercialized material then
Perret
right now has almost 40% share of carbon
fiber market
since as I said that she's you know
material it takes time to apply or apply
a new material to the to the good
application there are you know roots of
American company has been trying to go
into this carbon fiber market however
they give up almost all companies give
up this you know since its baby it takes
time to you know expand the business so
currently Japanese three producers
terrain auto wholly owned be Jewish
Miriam has the read in carbon fiber
beasts this is a current situation this
is my thought to get innovate on the
successful innovation or to realize the
innovative material we need a technology
or winning and as well as management
technology we need to have establishment
well we need to establish world number
one position in core technology and then
we need to put effort or continuous
development example material new
material takes time however it is an
to make revolutionary aircraft Boeing
seven seven without new materials that
is on Boeing severe seven Bowen Cole's
dream rain but that is not just a Boeing
stream torus dream we dreamed there to
make a carbon fiber airframe so Boeing
707 is kind of near the realization of
our dream and management management we
need I sold I think the management we
need the management with a long-term
vision in a study twenty thirteen years
and continuing and diligent investment
for technical development so we need
management has to have to be so
management we need to management need to
put continuing and urgent investment so
our carbon fiber business was in the red
ink all sorry yes so Newman that's why
you know other producers gave up during
this development
so new material takes a long time to get
certification so we need to endure the
that kind of
okay this is my last right so we really
believe that carbon fiber whoa
expand the application but key points
the cost reduction we don't be Cabo
fiber they're still the price of steel
it's almost you know ten dollars
sorry one bandura's wonder I wonder
Apache row or some selected well Cabo
fiber price is modern tendrils party row
so we need to make effort to reduce the
cost continuously of course we carbon
fiber has a spirit of Hormuz however
still the in order to make the carbon
fiber the main material but main you
know material to we need to reduce cost
production cost as well as total cost by
you know collaboration with the airplane
company or automobile company also we
need to seek we look for the new type of
demand automobile or aerospace
development you know SpaceX using a lot
of carbon fiber right now
so we gear we hope to expand the
disciplic ation
okay that's my presentation yes thank
you very much
you